le générique plusieurs jeux leclerc
et bien dit secondement suffit
jean-claude je suis effectivement vous
avez deviné à la micro boutique c'est à
dire à l'endroit où se passe la micro
informatique micro informatique qui est
aujourd'hui gratuite vous pouvez venir
aussi coop dans cette partie là
gratuitement
c'est très intéressant pour vous
renseigner vous renseigner sur quoi eh
bien d'abord les revues il y à des
revues en grande quantité voilà des
revues qui s'occupe de beaucoup de
machines à la fois de tous les micro
ordinateurs
il y en a pratiquement une par mois
voilà celle du mois d'octobre
septembre-octobre votre ordinateur c'est
le numéro un il ya maintenant des revues
qui s'occupe que d'une seule machine
voilà celle qui s'appelle traces
or 10,5 pom's ceux qui sont spécialisés
indien et au p magazine retrouvons les
siens si vous avez une machine
spécifique
si vous voulez savoir comment ça marche
c'est votre revue mais aussi comme vous
avez beaucoup de choses vous avez
notamment des choses très sportive et
une compétition demain matin qui se
passe entre des ordinateurs alors les
ordinateurs les voici
non c'est pas réussi là c'est là c'est
la sas et ceux qui programment les
ordinateurs ils ont programmé quoi un
jeu de thello moi je sais pas jouer à
l'hôtellerie les profs qui ne savent pas
très bien joué non plus alors ils ont
décidé de faire battre entre eux des
ordinateurs qui se battront demain et
qui essaieront de prouver que le
programme est meilleur ensuite quand ils
auront fini ils apprendront des langages
basique alors j'ai quelques livres en
basic le basique c'est le langage sur
lequel on veut insister aujourd'hui que
vous achetiez un livre vous preniez ça
sous forme de disque est le basique
c'est quelque chose qui est universel
mais qu'on trouve la plupart du temps en
anglais alors je vais lancer un appel
ici à tous les téléspectateurs qui
souhaitent que le basic langage
universel encore une fois se passe en
français regardez ces machines si vous
voyez sur l'écran par exemple télé micro
affiche
s'ils demandent page répète affiche tout
cela c'est du français ce n'est pas
seulement cela règle du jeu qui est en
français c'est la programmation la
programmation en basic a été mise au
point par certains spécialistes
en voici un georges accarias tenez vous
bien il est libanais il a été étudiant à
l'université de l'illinois aux états
unis et il est dans une société anglaise
c'est des gens comme ça qui s'occupe de
notre basique en français alors antenne
2 a décidé de les aider georges vous
êtes prêt à mettre au point un basique
que tous nos téléspectateurs voudront
bien sûr sa dette déjà fait sur un grand
nombre d'ordinateurs de grand public
par exemple ces deux machines là et
c'est possible de l'adapter sur
plusieurs ordinateurs aujourd'hui
alors si vous voulez avoir un basique en
français vous nous écrivez à télé micro
15 rue cognacq jay paris 7e et on fera
tous ensemble le basique de la france
avec toutes nos machines notamment des
petites machines d'initiation comme
cette machine anglaise qui coûte pas
cher la france n'a jamais cru à ces
machines jusqu'à aujourd'hui où on
présente en exclusivité à l'iss voyez
c'est à peu près la même taille ça la
même fonction ce sont des machines
d'initiation qui seront très rapidement
en français voilà la machine hector qui
elle aussi a décidé de passer en
français elle parlait anglais avant oui
d'ailleurs jaun offre il sait tout ça
c'est du passé
la machine hector fabriqué en france se
doit de parler français et antennes de
et tous les téléspectateurs de télé
micro vont en faire autant dernière
chose jean claude christian poulin si
vous vous souvenez
si vous êtes un fana de la
micro-informatique christian a gagné un
concours micro il ya trois ans c'était
le petit génie à l'époque christian
qu'est-ce que vous êtes vous devenu
aujourd'hui dans trois ans on peut faire
beaucoup d'informatique et
particulièrement justement en
informatique a évolué assez vite
vous êtes tous là encore assez haché
encore lycée je suis en maths spé au
lycée saint-louis général et vous fait
toujours de la micro-informatique et
même de l'informatique maintenant
puisque une chance énorme et on sait
j'ai eu accès aux ordinateurs du palais
les couverts et comme chacun sait elle
pas les clients c'est une institution
qui est vraiment fantastique est libre
la voyez à quoi ça met de la
micro-informatique jean-claude je vous
répète dans que ceux ci comme ouvert
demain au grand public samedi le
dimanche est fermé mais toute la semaine
prochaine est ouverte vous donnera tous
les renseignements possibles ici dans
cette boutique sur le parvis de la
défense pour ceux qui ont la chance de
pouvoir venir à paris sur la micro
informatique les livres les manuels les
revues les machines qui parlent français
aussi les autres à la semaine prochaine
et bien la semaine prochaine georges
pour vous retrouver avec vos ordinateurs
en quittant je voudrais vous rappeler le
tempo